this is a production of Cornell
University
they've they've mentioned that I've been
doing a lot of traveling my primary
responsibility for this year and
probably for the next two years is to be
training on our conservation planners
within the Natural Resources
Conservation Service they all have to be
certified for conservation planning and
one of the courses that are required is
the economics of conservation planning
so we teach the we've been teaching I've
got eight weeks of summer I've been
teaching it and we've got other
counterparts that are teaching as well
but we have to change we have to do
within five years 3,000 employees so
what I've done though for this
particular talk is taking some
principles that we teach our planners
and applied it to the soil health
concepts or for you guys and then I'm
going to winnow it down and actually
talk about soil health in New York and
some case studies that have been done
here in New York that I helped there was
a retired economist Flo Schwartz who has
worked with them and one of the case
studies actually is Dave Magus farm and
so we'll um i'll handle is out at the
end so it doesn't kind of take you away
from my talk
down-arrow you said okay so I'm gonna
talk about a little bit about the
difference on soil health management
practices NRCS will now provide
technical and financial assistance for
our more practices rural health related
with these are kind of the core
practices that are used within NRCS
most of the contradiction tillage
rotation a cover cropping field borders
riparian buffers nutrient and integrated
pest management so how do economists
compare these different practices and
help to provide information to producers
so that they can make an informed
decision what would work for them in
their particular operation so what we do
is we buy things of course into the
benefits and cost and in the benefits
and our CS looks at things according to
what we call swap ax which is soil water
air plants animals and then we added
energy and then also a human
considerations so those are the type of
benefit categories that we look at when
we're comparing things and we do this
not only for our farm but we do this
when we're looking at policy analysis as
well it's consistent and the costs of
course are the consistent over the
beautiful economic cost of land labor
capital management English and in this
case but all farming on-farm benefits
will differ it just depends on the
viewpoint if you're looking from a
policy viewpoint you're looking at the
off farm benefits and for to be talking
to a producer about implementing
practices of course we're looking at
what is the impact of them so these are
some templates that we have developed I
believe Paul maybe can help me or maybe
some contributions here is around 130
practices or so that we don't have
standards and specifications for so a
counterpart of mine took those 130
practices templates and they basically
take the categories that I showed you
before and talked about for each of
these practices
what could the potential positive
effects and negative effects be for a
producer if they were to implement that
practice and that's helpful because when
a conservation planner goes on a farm
and they want to chocolate
laundry list to start with and there
might be some additional things that are
particularly on that farm but it's a
really good laundry list that you can go
through and say okay this doesn't apply
here but something else does and it
helps them categorize the benefits in
the costs so I gave an example here of
cover cropping we call those tea charts
by the way
okay so when you're looking at um
economics and what we teach our
conservation plan is we're really
looking at the change from before to
after we don't have to look at
everything we don't have to look at
enterprise budgets and all that unless
we're um really winnowing down to
something we're talking to our producers
we're just looking at the positive
effects and the negative effects of the
change before and after so of course the
positive effects from a partial budget
would be increased revenues or reduced
costs and the negative effects for the
increased cost or decreased revenue I'm
gonna try to help make up time um so
what we do is we take put those concepts
and then we go through mighty charts
which come up with the different
categories we should be looking at and
this we call level one which is just
descriptive so in this case we're
looking at the positive effects might be
um treatment here what they've done is
they've combined different practices
into what we call a system and the
system is looking at the whole system on
a field or on a farm or whatever it
would be could be just one practice or
it could be a combination of practices
so combination of practices is the
system so in this case we have a
conservation treat treatment they have
crop rotation residue management pest
management and nutrient management and
then we go through that I would talk
about the positive effects and the
negative effects of that and so in the
descriptive we're just talking about
yield increasing increasing if they're
getting a financial assistance payment
that would be an increased revenue on
down and then the negative effects would
be um you have to buy no-till drill or
you know pesum and increased pest
management those type of things
or in a short time period you may
actually lose production so we outline
all of that for a producer tried you
okay I jumped to a level three a level
two just real briefly as you start
putting numbers to them they don't have
to be consistent it might be like
savings tons of soil per acre or buying
a no-till drill at twenty thousand
dollars or something like that and then
what the third example does
it puts it in like terms so in this case
you prop rotation and there's a formula
that you can come up with determine what
the average cost per acre per year is I
won't put into detail but it can be done
um you can reduce the cost by decreasing
fertilizer reducing tillage passes
reducing fuel and labor there's other
positive effects um improve soil and
water quality and you may have some sort
of habitat improvement for wildlife and
then the negative affects what they do
is they take something like a purchased
milled thrill and we amortize it over a
time period and that when you do all
that then you can come up with $1 for
acre per year positive impacts and
negative impact so if you look
let me see here what the wrong button
didn't I
okay there you go down here that's the
sum of all the benefits on $60 per acre
per year in this example and then the
negative affects the total is $22 per
acre per year and so the net benefits
would be thirty-eight dollars per acre
three
so another thing that we do is we take
all this information and a lot of
producers might say well this all sounds
well and good but how does this really
work I'd like to talk to people or I'd
like to see some examples of real life
experiences so that's what we're doing
the case studies and the benefit is that
usually we use the partial budget
technique
it does give real-world examples we work
with the producers to develop them um a
good case study is not just a shining
example it also shows the hardships that
they've gone through to get to where
they are and that's really important
because we don't want to paint a rosy
picture all the time but they're gonna
have trials and trips when they do when
they change what they're doing um but
you want to make sure that it's
relatable so whoever your your audience
is so you pick a producer that's either
is respected or it relates they've got
very similar circumstances to the
audience that you're trying to provide
this basically for and um one thing I
want to say is when you look at these
case studies and there's a lot of them
out there you want to look read it with
a critical eye because different people
have different agendas and there's some
times when they say all this looks
really really good you've really got to
get into the numbers to see if it's if
they're accurate or not sometimes they
inflate benefits or they decrease costs
and things like that so make sure that
when you're looking at things that
you're really reading it with a critical
eye and ask no questions
okay okay so I'm going to the two
examples that I'm going to hand out to
people if you're interested or angel
Rose dairy and in this case they did um
both of these are in central New York
around Ontario northern Watertown area I
believe what is in social New York
somewhere right yeah
okay and that's the angel Rose dairy
what they have been doing no-till and
cover crop and then 350 acres and the
total net benefits um it's over eight
thousand dollars or twenty four dollars
per acre per year and that you can read
more details about this I'll hand it out
in these paste on the pronounce the
other thing I want to say about the case
studies is we try to make them two pages
to hand out they're meant to go to field
days and things like that so that people
can very quickly fitmom look at it and
it's not a whole bunch of papers they
don't have to delve into a lot of
research or whatever they can cut to the
chase right away um it's fine now it
wasn't interesting that you're up to
eight eight hundred cows now I think
ours was uh six six seventy or somewhere
around there and we did the case study
so it's great that you're able to
increase production on your farm um but
anyway uh if there was to 2,200 acres at
that point which was two years ago I
believe had told them that benefits of
over seventy eight thousand dollars for
sixty two dollars per acre per year
you
so some things to remember when you're
doing partial budgeting or looking at a
button is when you adopt a conservation
system you are looking at a long term
investment especially with soil health
it's going to take time it depends on
how degraded your soil is you're gonna
see actually I think they say that
you'll see more benefits thicker and
more degraded soil then very improve
their economic from also result in
economic benefits um
and an example is the the reduced yield
variability so if you're reducing risk
as soil health increases you're not
going to get them as much of a wild
swing in yields that you might have had
before and sometimes that's hard to
quantify and it's something to be
discussed and in order to realize the
greatest benefits for the system you
have to figure out the system that works
best on your operation given your
challenges and goals and I think that's
it
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu